buonasera a tutti io sono qua e senza
fatta di semplicità tanto è vero che
qualcuno
che ho scoperto l'acqua calda con i
social street
qualcun altro mi dice no ma forse più un
tè me lo direte voi alla fine di questa
esposizione che cos'è per voi fatto sta
che oggi è socia scritte diventato un
fenomeno diffuso sta diffondendo in
tutto il mondo e ci sono noti accademici
di varie università di varie parti del
mondo che se ne stanno occupando
partiamo dall'inizio vi siete mai
sentiti stranieri nella propria città
a me è capitato quando mi sono
trasferito a bologna io sono nato e
cresciuto in un piccolo paese non
lontano quando a pisa e della mia strada
ci si conosceva un po tutti mi sentivo
parte di una comunità
faccio un esempio banale ancora oggi mia
mamma quando sta preparando la cena e
magari sono le nove di sera si accorge
che manca il sale o le uova esce di casa
sono al vicino per prende in prestito
normale no bene questa normalità
io quando mi sono trasferito a bologna
non sono mai riuscito a ricrearla in
città i rapporti sono molto più rigidi
se ti suonano alle nove di sera il
campanello salti sulla sedia ed ai due
mandate perché non stai aspettando
nessuno oggi nelle città
purtroppo secondo me ci siamo un po
irrigiditi ci siamo anche in this
abituati alle relazioni
se ci pensate bene possiamo dare anche
se volete possiamo dare colpo anche al
tempo effettivamente abbiamo 24 ore in
una giornata otto ore le dedichiamo il
sonno otto ore le diciamo al lavoro le
altre otto ore sarebbero quelle da
dedicare alle relazioni
però è anche vero che per esempio come
nel mio caso io impiego due ore per
andare a lavorare due ore per tornare
francamente il tempo a disposizione non
è moltissimo
se poi a questo aggiungiamo il ruolo che
in questo caso negativamente hanno
svolto le tecnologie
ecco come ci ritroviamo
non so se voi vi ritrovate in questa
fotografia io mi ritrovo e non sono
quello nel pallino rosso prima degli
smartphone
era normale anche non so quando uno si
perdeva in una città chiedere
disconosciuto delle indicazioni no
quindi interagiva con qualcuno che non
conosceva
oggi tutti abbiamo lo smartphone che
schiacciare un tasto e avete la
soluzione non avete bisogno di parlare
con nessuno
ebbene fatto tutto questa premessa io
quando mi sono trasferita in via
fondazza avvertivo questo ha senso di
indifferenza di solitudine se volete
qual è stata la molla che mi ha spinto a
portare avanti il social street
questo questo e matteo mio figlio che ho
adesso tre anni avendo le famiglie mia e
di mia moglie che vivono lontano lui
giocava tutti i giorni da solo nella sua
nella sua cameretta è però dicevo è
possibile che in una strada di 400 metri
ci saranno altre famiglie come entrare
in relazione con loro senza essere
invasivo come conoscere i miei vicini
bene volevo risolvere questo problema
non esasperando l'utilizzo della
tecnologia che come vi ho detto secondo
me ci ha portato a questo punto quindi
ho escluso fin dall'inizio la creazione
dell'ennesimo piattaforma la creazione
dell'ennesima up
oggi c'è un app per fare tutto quante up
avete voi sul sul telefonino 10 12
quante ne usate tutti i giorni una 2
un recente studio in america dice che su
cinque minuti di navigazione da
smartphone un minuto viene speso su
facebook bene avevo già la mia risposta
lo strumento c'era non era quello il
problema
quindi ho semplicemente fatto una cosa
banalissima ho creato un gruppo chiuso
su facebook chiamandolo residente in via
fondazza nome della messa da bologna la
parte interessante è stata utilizzare
facebook e in un modo invertendo il
paradigma di solito facebook serve per
mettere in contatto le persone che
vivono a
migliaia di chilometri di distanza per
tenere in contatto ho detto bene
proviamo ad utilizzarlo per fare diciamo
iniziare a relazionare vicini che
abitano a 10 metri di distanza e vediamo
che succede
poi ho stampato dei semplici volantini
in quei burattini tipo questi qui una
società che l'ha fatto dopo di me era un
messaggio generico non avevo scritto che
cercava michetti per mio figlio
semplicemente chiedevo di iscriversi a
questo gruppo perché volevo conoscere
chi stava nella mia strada
bene siamo nell'agosto del 2013
avevo fatto una scommessa con mia moglie
che oggi qui in sala con me e io che
sono il pessimista della famiglia dicevo
che si sarebbero iscritti 15 persone con
un messaggio così poi vago detto sicuro
le persone sono diffidenti lei ottimista
diceva se ne sarebbero scritto una
trentina
ebbene come vedrete dopo i numeri sono
un po un po diversi ma cos'è dunque
social street
beh i sociologi universita si sono
sbizzarrite definizione cioè che l'ha
definita un acceleratore di fiducia
gli studenti dello ied di milano l'hanno
definito un desiderio di socialità ai
tempi di face ai tempi di facebook
io semplicemente lo definisco sentirsi a
casa quando non quando aprì il portone
di casa e se nelle sue quattro mura
domestiche ma quando materialmente entri
nella tua nella tua strada e per me oggi
è così se oggi devo prendere il treno è
meglio che esco una decina di minuti
prima perché adesso tutte le persone che
vedevo erano solo volti in molti casi
adesso sono amici sono relazioni vi
racconto questa una breve storia che
che ha portato la società street sul tg
il tg1 e questo è una storia di banalità
di semplicità ma che rappresenta bene lo
spirito c'è un ragazzo uno studente che
si appena trasferita in via fondazza non
conosce la zona 9 di sera si accorge che
si rompe la lavatrice
all'indomani deve a un colloquio di
lavoro quindi panico non sa cosa fare
deve lavare la camicia fa un posto nel
gruppo e dice vicini sapete se ci sono
delle lavanderie a gettone una vicina
risponde no mi dispiace non ci sono
lavanderie a gettone qui
e poi aggiunge tu dove abiti abito il
civico 79 e la ragazza risponde anche io
abito al civico 79 queste persone non si
erano mai mai incrociati nel palazzo
quindi gli dice semplicemente bene ciò
la lavatrice in cantina viene prendere
la chiave e ti do la chiave e file e
lavatrice ok grazie ciao fine semplice
banale dire non sembra perché arriva la
troupe del tg1 prima domanda che lei lei
giornalista fa a questa ragazza dice
perché lei ha aiutato uno sconosciuto
lei dice per effettivamente è uno
sconosciuto
non lo conoscevo però ero mio vicino era
in difficoltà non avevo niente insomma
non mi costava niente aiutarlo l'ho
aiutato seconda domanda e lei cos'ha
avuto in cambio e la risposta
rivoluziona rissi ma di questa ragazza
che rappresenta un po lo spirito social
street ed eri veramente rivoluzionaria
nei tempi in cui viviamo oggi è stata
niente oggi siamo abituati a pensare ea
vivere in un mondo dove nessuno fa
niente per niente c'è sempre un do ut
des sono scambi un qualcosa non dare una
vera faccia scritto dimostra che può
andare avanti anche al di là dei
meccanismi economici che ci governano
quindi come funziona materialmente
social scritte no
qui c'è manca mi sono scusato una slide
allora c'è uno slogan che ha coniato un
mio vicino di casa e co fondatore di
società italia che è luigi che la
chiamata ha creato questo slogan che
dice dal virtuale al reale al virtuoso
questi sono i vari passaggi quindi come
come come avviene la vita nelle società
scritti in modo molto semplice se sono
piccole storie che adesso vi racconto
che però sono importanti per creare
relazione e capitale sociale come dicono
i sociologi che stanno studiando questo
questo fenomeno per creare comunità
non lo so qui per esempio siamo a roma a
pomezia è un signore alla consolle del
figlio che servano sembra essere rotta e
quindi chiede se invece di portare in
assistenza dice beh prima vedere se il
cavetto che non va quindi chiede vicini
se qualcuno ha un cavetto che si accorge
che la persona del palazzo possono né
anno hanno la stessa console e quindi
può possono lo può aiutare quindi queste
persone con questo pretesto si sono
conosciute quindi cioè sottolineo questo
questo aspetto perché non è solo un
discorso di condivisione tant'è vero che
spesso social street viene associato a
un l'ennesimo fenomeno di share e mi
economy di cui si parla tanto
qui più che altro elemento importante è
la relazione che vengono scaturiti da
queste piccole cose no non è il gesto in
sé qua non so una signora semplicemente
aveva perso gli occhiali no uno dice
parti gli occhiali e ci pazienza e ne
comprerò prova a fare un post per vedere
se vicini le hanno trovate invece le
avevano poi trovati l'avevano lasciata e
l'edicola quindi un problema che è mio
nella società street lo posso
condividere con gli altri e posso avere
anche una risposta dai miei vicini
spesso c'è sempre una risposta difficile
che poste rimangono inascoltati qua e
fabio a milano è un altro esempio di dal
virtuale al reale al virtuoso ha bisogno
di un telo così da per fare una
proiezione prima della società scritto
cosa avrebbe fatto sarebbero al centro
commerciale avrebbe comprato un telo
l'avrebbe usato quella sera poi avrebbe
messo in cantina e avrebbe preso polvere
ha detto proviamo a vedere se pime
vicini hanno un telo e non uno ma tre
persone
ce lo hanno e quindi fanno quasi a gara
per portarlo tutte persone che lui non
conosceva quindi a km zero anzi a m 0
risolve risolve un problema o qua
semplicemente siamo a milano in via
morgagni una ragazza che vive da sola
che è malata non si può alzare dal letto
per comprare le medicine chiede aiuto e
vicinissimi non perdono un attimo per
rispondere e per dare una mano alla
ragazza
queste sono occasioni che poi chi ha
prevalso c'è scritto cerca di portare
dal virtuale al reale le persone cioè
crea uno degli eventi
osservando quali sono le cose che
interessano nella società scritta in
questo caso era un trekking fra vicini
di casa sono ritrovato una mattina per
esplorare le zone vicino casa qua siamo
via maiocchi a milano una signora che
esperta di arte si è offerta di portare
i vicini in giro per conoscere magari
dei musei poco mostri milano questo è un
mio vicino di casa marco qua siamo che
dimostra proprio come abitare una
società scritte basta semplicemente
anche cambiare semplicemente
l'attitudine mentale non ci vuole molto
c'è stata questa nevicata a gennaio lui
deve sperare il vialetto di casa quindi
va in cantina a prendere la palla fa la
sua cosa pulisce la vialetto il violetto
sta per tornare in cantina e poi dice ma
io abito in una società street
probabilmente quello è un mio problema è
anche cielo anche mia vicina di casa
allora tornano in strada si fa un self i
pala e nel scrive su facebook
lascio questo palo al frutta e verdura
della strada e chiunque mi ha bisogno di
andare a prendere quel giorno altre
persone risolvono un problema semplice
dire no questa qui è la social bike di
affondarsi anche per i stesso discorso
c'erano molti studenti che chiedevano se
qualcuno aveva una bicicletta da
prestare dove si trovavano potevano
trovare bicicletta poco bene un posto
abbiamo detto quante biciclette ci sono
in cantina che non usate usati una volta
bene ce ne erano c'erano diversi vicini
che hanno hanno risposto abbiamo detto
bene mettiamole in via fondazza a metà
della piazzetta dove a metà della strada
e chiunque ne ha bisogno la va a
prendere lasciamole chiave dal nostro
amico frutta e verdura ma sud e senza
documenti senza cauzione
niente soltanto sulla fiducia dei vicini
in casa ognuno abbiamo una sorta di bike
sharing basato su sulla strada qua siamo
in via maiocchi la domenica mattina si
ritrova in un piccolo orto urbano mobile
che hanno ricavato per fare l'aperitivo
e dove hanno coltivano delle piante qua
siamo sempre in via fondazza un mio
vicino di casa giovanni aveva osservato
nel gruppo che infondate c'erano diversi
artisti c'erano avanscoperta c'erano i
poeti c'erano musicisti c'erano pittori
allora organizzato una giornata
invitando tutti i vicini di casa
scendere in strada portando la propria
arte per conoscere i vicini che ti
stanno accanto sotto delle magari degli
aspetti che tu non conoscevi qui per
esempio hanno organizzato dei gruppi di
acquisto solidale non questo il momento
della distribuzione del delle consegne
delle verdure diventa anche un momento
di socialità fra vicini o qua per
esempio il problema del lavoro che ormai
è un problema che riguarda molte persone
questa vicina in modo molto semplice
dice visto che devo cercare lavoro per
me approfitto per selezionare delle
offerte lavoro anche per i miei vicini
di casa che magari a me non interessano
certe offerte le selezioni quindi a
volte uno si scoraggia anche cercare
lavoro perché insomma diventa che è
logorante e bene anche con questi
piccoli gesti si creano contatti se si
innesca la virtuosità di cui punto lo
slogan lo so mi dicevo dicevo prima bene
come avete visto il minimo comune
denominatore tutte queste storie è che
viene fatto tutto a costo zero
tutto quello che avete visto serve
esclusivamente per creare relazioni per
creare senso di comunità di appartenenza
basata sulla condivisione
nessun giro di soldi non servono non
serve niente oggi le società strette si
sono diffuse un po diciamo questa è in
italia sono 350
questa è la mappa quelle che sono in in
europa e nel mondo sono 380 proprio due
giorni fa mi hanno scritto anche dalle
canarie che ne partirà anche un alle
canarie e quindi viene da chiedersi
com'è possibile che si sia sviluppato
così un un'idea perché è che questo che
è perché adesso andiamo ad analizzare
anche le caratteristiche social street
non è dietro non c'è un business plan
non c'è non è una start up cioè conosco
bene quel mondo in economia qua pisa e e
proprio perché conoscevo quel mondo lo
volevo lasciare fuori
volevo fare l'opposto volevo lasciare il
mondo economico delle regole non ho
voluto registrare ai marchi niente
volevo che questa idea semplice
veicolasse il più possibile dando dei
buoni esempi basta solo questo
e devo dire che ha funzionato gli
elementi caratterizzanti il quale sono
stati sicuramente l'informalità perché
assetto quindi non ha una sede
non ci sono tessere non è
un'associazione non è un comitato non è
niente sono un gruppo di cittadini che
si mettono insieme in un gruppo facebook
molto semplice
l'altro elemento importante come vedete
prima e la gratuita quindi tutto quello
che muove si basa sull'economia del dono
che serve quindi per creare relazione e
poi l'inclusività perché consoce street
sono andato a delimitare un territorio
ben preciso che la strada lasciando
fuori tutte quelle categorie in cui oggi
noi ci auto ghettizzano non c'è l'estra
comunitario italiano il vecchio il
giovane no ci sono i residenti di quella
strada bene oggi io posso dire che vivo
molto meglio nella nella mia nella mia
strada il mio obiettivo è stato
raggiunto così come quello vi posso dire
che molti altri social street e che
hanno iniziato questa avventura possono
possono dire lo stesso adesso potete
dire voi so scoperto l'acqua calda o
forse qualcosa a qualcosa di più però
volevo ringraziare essenzialmente i miei
vicini di casa che grazie a loro sono
qua a raccontare questa storia è mai me
lo sarei immaginato e e vi ringrazio voi
per l'attenzione
[Musica]
[Applauso]